[Music]
how come I've never heard of this lake
situated between Montenegro and Albania
Lakes Qatar is the largest inland body
of water in the Balkans it's deserted
villages are few and far between it's
just a vast expanse of unspoiled nature
scada lake is the home of more than 280
species of birds so it is one of the
richest bird hotspots in Europe
containing more than half of the whole
European species including Dalmatian
pelicans although sightings are rare
ornithologist and rave easy from the
Natural History Museum of Montenegro
knows exactly where we're most likely to
catch a glimpse of them and sure enough
there they are the pelicans are the
largest freshwater bird in the world and
that means exactly this species that we
have here as Caddo Lake the Dalmatian
Pelican so their wingspan is regularly
over two meters and in the biggest
specimens it can be more than three
meters I guess the the biggest recorded
number is three hundred and ten
centimeters that's the wingspan
the good news is that their numbers are
increasing the shallow waters and peace
and quiet make Lake SCADA an ideal
habitat but what is most contributed to
the recent rise in the Dalmatian Pelican
population is an international
conservation project floating breeding
platforms have been mounted it's not
uncommon for Pelican chicks to drown
when the lake floods as it frequently
does unfortunately our arrival has
scared the pelicans off but the heaps of
nests are proof positive that the
pelicans appreciate the breeding
platforms and rave Izzie has already
counted 60 chicks this year a record
number it's lovely here on Lake scatter
the birds the tranquility the
picturesque villages it's not even hard
to reach and I'm surprised it hasn't
been discovered as a tourist destination
I meet Yvonne's individuai on it
happening soon he's in charge of what's
about to become a massive construction
site the Lake scada National Park will
soon be home to a holiday resort
according to the website it will
comprise a high-end hotel luxury villas
a restaurant a private jet e and
spectacular views the project adheres to
the highest environmental standards says
in the vich he insists the region will
benefit economically from the new resort
first of all we are going to create the
jobs for the people so they will have a
reason to stay they can make they own
their homes and their families
sustainable the second is that we are
going to buy the products from them we
are going to buy the wine that they are
producing food that they are producing
organic food of course and we are going
to give them a reason to stay
environmental activists beg to differ
many believe it could pave the way for
even more construction in the
conservation area
bianca Pratley at church works on the
pelican conservation project and opposes
large-scale projects of this kind my
vision of that I think is best for
scatter Lake is to really go back to the
local communities there is there is a
lot of values there there is a their
cultural and historical heritage that is
beautiful they have beautiful music
music recipes they have it's really
undiscovered treasure some in the
village of Bodom imagine tourists
enjoying this natural bathing area one
day there's no shortage of locally grown
produce and many homes have empty rooms
that could be led to visitors Emmons on
maja has founded an initiative to boost
local tourism it pains him to see the
growing number of people leaving paadam
because there's no work here he welcomes
the Pelican conservation project the
village is close to the Dalmatian
Pelican colony and home to a new Ranger
base bianca Pratley at church would like
to see more local support for the
project she has nothing against
ecotourism is the one who who is
organizing this type of offer and if the
local community has pelicans as their
business partner to say like that they
will protect the colony with all cost
and I'm sure that Rangers will will have
much less things to do around the
pelican colony and protection is vital
webcam images show just how sensitive
the pelicans are to any form of
disturbance for now the few people who
venture into the conservation area tend
to be fishermen who mainly come at night
they scare away the pelicans which fly
off and abandon the eggs they're
hatching
close to the colony we encounter a
fishing net that shouldn't be here it
contains a few fish water scorpions a
water rat
and the snake sensitive Dalmatian
pelicans eager investors fishermen in
need of a livelihood by the end of my
trip I've realized that Lakes Qatar is
by no means as deserted as I'd thought
it's likely that a lot will change here
in the years to come
I hope that whatever development takes
place it won't spoil this breathtakingly
beautiful region
[Music]
you